c'est aujourd'hui la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida 33 millions
personnes atteintes dans le monde et
malgré les campagnes d'information il
faut continuer à parler prévention a
informé ainsi d'après un sondage 81 %
des jeunes interrogés reconnaissent
d'avoir peur du sida
et ils ne sont plus que 19 % à utiliser
systématiquement un préservatif
autre chiffre révélateur 74% d'entre eux
n'ont jamais fait de test de dépistage
et cela alors qu'en france
quarante mille personnes sont porteuses
du virus du sida
sans le savoir il faut donc encore et
toujours inciter au dépistage mais
latente des résultats est parfois jugée
beaucoup trop longue
le reportage de nathalie sapina et chloé
cormery c'est une démarche que sylvain
gilbert fait régulièrement un test pour
le sida dans un centre de dépistage
je prends trois tubes comme je fais en
plus du vih d'autres examens son but
vérifier se rassurer même sans pratiques
sexuelles à risque
le test est toujours une épreuve attend
dans une semaine son résultat c'est
quelqu'un c'est sinon c'est vraiment
c'est toujours très long mais vraiment
on se demande toujours sait jamais si
c'est positif
qu'est ce que je vais devenir qu'est ce
qui va m'arriver si sylvain gilibert
avait habité amsterdam
il aurait pu obtenir son résultat en 15
minutes
car ici les tests rapides sont utilisés
depuis cinq ans par exemple à
l'association checkpoint tous les
vendredis soir les bénévoles font passer
les tests un test salivaire a laissé et
un test sanguin en piquant juste le bout
du doigt
c'est très simple
la seule chose dont vous avez besoin une
goutte de sang la dépose sur la bande et
safran 15 minutes pour un résultat 100%
fiable
c'est cette rapidité qui a motivé jan à
46 ans et malgré une vie sexuelle active
c'est la première fois qu'ils ont osé
faire ce test ça m'a pris du temps pour
me décider à faire ce test
mais quand on est décidé on a envie
d'une réponse rapide
c'était possible ici amsterdam et je
suis venue de rotterdam 160 km
aller-retour le pour savoir
immédiatement le test rapide attire
aussi des gens particulièrement
angoissée comme marie 17 ans attendre ça
me tue pas de sexe j'ai fait l'amour
sans préservatif
avec trois personnes maintenant j'ai un
copain je veux m'engager
ces tests rapides sont parfaitement
adaptés aux personnes les plus fragiles
en landau aux états unis de plus en plus
de gens passent un test mais ne vont pas
chercher leurs résultats après une ou
deux semaines
donc vous voulez tester pour rien car
passer un test c'est aussi une occasion
utile de revoir les bases de la
prévention un accompagnement
indispensable
c'est l'heure des résultats un seul
trait rouge sur la bande
le test de yann est négatif c'est une
bonne nouvelle
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle vous êtes
heureux oui très
qu allez vous changer dans votre
comportement je vais toujours utiliser
des préservatifs c'est très important
en france ces tests rapides non
autorisés actuellement vont être
expérimentées en 2008 ce que réclame
depuis un an le conseil national du sida
aujourd'hui il est temps de banaliser
cette procédure parce qu'elle n'a aucun
inconvénient
aucun elle n'a que des avantages à la
fois individuel et collectif
l'enjeu des pistes et les 40000
personnes séropositives qui ignorent
encore leur statut